[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[за підтримки «Лавка традицій».
Продукти від маленьких господарств]
[Селисько,
Галичина]
Ми займаємось ремісничим сироварінням,
виготовляємо молоду групу сирів,
витримані сири, йогурти, масло.
Ми обрали повільний спосіб життя,
і це дуже класно.
[Вікторія Книш
Співзасновниця сироварні]
Ми почали приїжджати щодня в село,
і я спочатку не могла повірити,
що може бути такий спокій,
що може бути така тиша.
Ми не поспішаємо,
ми насолоджуємось моментами:
приїхали гості — чудово!
Посиділи, відпочили.
Не приїхали — працюємо далі.
Ми знаходимось на території
фермерського господарства,
яким займаються наші друзі:
вони утримують корів
голшитини і джерсейської породи.
Вони дуже соціальні, дуже люблять людей.
Ну що?
Чим характерна корова породи джерсей?
Вона, як бачите, є невеликого зросту,
тобто відповідно трошки менше у неї
іде потреба в кормах,
і в неї — надзвичайно жирне молоко.
Воно за вмістом жиру наближається до овечого.
Тут близько шести відсотків показники.
Ця ферма була одна з небагатьох в Україні,
де були джерсеї.
Це була страшна рідкість!
Тут просто полювали за тими теличками.
Коли ми приїжджали на фестиваль,
до мене зразу підходили:
«Чи у вас можна купити джерсеїв?»
У мене джерсеїв немає, у мене є сир.
Тепер коротко про кругообіг молока в природі.
З ферми молоко до нас приїжджає
у молочному танкері.
І далі воно йде в роботу:
розподіляється в залежності від того,
що у нас на сьогодні заплановано — які сири.
Від молока до порізки всі сири, практично,
робляться однаково.
Яким чином ми отримуємо різні смаки,
різні структури?
Ми регулюємо це різноманітними заквасками.
Запрограмованого сиру немає,
тому що є різна погода, корови в різному настрої,
кожен день молоко має свої нюанси.
Його потрібно відчувати тільки на руку.
Найбільш чутливий є сир кисломолочний.
Він може кваситись вчасно,
він може кваситись із запізненням на годину,
на півтори.
Деколи ніби починається все так гарно,
а зранку приходиш — замість сиру маєш рідке молоко.
Що сталося? Чому?
На якомусь етапі, навіть, хотіли відмовитися
від виробництва цього сиру,
але, з нашими галицькими традиціями,
у нас львів'яни не можуть жити
без кисломолочного сиру.
Ми спробували зменшити [виробництво],
але нам це не вдалося.
І от уже восьмий рік, день у день
у нас є сир кисломолочний.
Коли ми даємо сир на дозрівання,
тобто на афінаж,
то починається вже певна магія,
тому що біля нього треба потанцювати,
з ним треба порозмовляти.
Тут, насправді, досить така кропітка робота,
тому що кожен сир вимагає до себе окремого підходу.
Стараємось, щоб не було зайвої вологи на сирі,
бо теж не дуже добре,
але максимально так розмиваємо скориночку.
Насправді, коли в нас є жива, їстівна скоринка —
вона зовсім інший дає смак:
підшкірний отой смак гарний буде.
Це зовсім інша пісня.
Цьому сиру — вже місяці два,
тобто з ним ще щонайменше чотири місяці ми попрацюємо,
і тоді віддамо клієнту.
Починати, насправді, було дуже важко,
тому що інколи невдалі експерименти
зовсім перекривали прибутки наші.
Але ми продовжували експерименти,
ми продовжували вдосконалюватись.
Щороку я вважала за потрібне їхати навчатися.
Це найкраща інвестиція, насправді, що є —
це інвестиція в своє навчання, у свою освіту.
З такого персонального викладання у мене був
тільки дуже знаний сировар у Польщі.
Він не приховував знань своїх,
він показував все, що він умів.
Я жила в їхньому будинку,
і я за це нічого не платила,
просто працювала, вчилася.
Це було фантастично нереально,
тому коли до мене звертаються зараз
сировари-початківці за якоюсь консультацією,
я кажу: «Приїжджайте, будь ласка».
Кажу: «Базові знання, базові речі я вам дам».
Як? Ото безкоштовно?
Кажу: «У свій час мені таке було дано,
і тому я мушу комусь це віддати».
Основна маса сироварів —
це просто така спільнота позитивно налаштованих,
ненормальних людей.
В основному всі з них — з двома,
з трьома вищими освітами,
які прийшли вже в досить
дорослому віці до сироваріння.
Всі — різними шляхами.
Пробуєш якось визначити основні тенденції —
неможливо,
тому що кожен якимись своїми манівцями
йшов до сироваріння.
Таких, хто від початку мав фахову освіту,
і йшов конкретно по цьому напрямку, там немає.
У нас — сімейна ферма, тобто працює
чоловік, я, і наші діти.
У нас четверо дітей.
[Анна Темчишин
Фермерка, підприємиця]
Мені здається, що такі ферми —
це ферми майбутнього,
де є безперервний цикл:
тваринництво, рослинництво і переробка.
Відповідно буде і розвиток села.
Про Селисько, як то кажуть, щораз більше говорять,
що в нас тут такі гарні сусіди як Скарбова гора.
Поряд ще є в нас вино, хто продукує малинове вино.
І відповідно в нас є сир, вино, і місце,
де гарно провести час.
Це є наш спосіб життя вже,
це — наше хобі.
Нам це подобається. Направду!
Я, нарешті, зрозуміла...
Ну, ми досить пізно прийшли до сироваріння,
я зрозуміла, що це — наше, що це наша тема.
Ми, нарешті, знайшли те, що нам подобається,
те, що ми робимо.
І зразу піднімається настрій,
я себе дуже вільно почуваю.
Мені весело, мені класно.
Мені це дуже приємно!
Фантастично приємно.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Режисерка
Марія Теребус]
[Режисерка монтажу
Оля Балицька]
[Оператори
Олег Сологуб, Назар Назарук]
Макс Завалля, Павло Пашко]
[Звукорежисерка
Анастасія Климова]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]